if you are dieting and exercising and
not getting results the issue might be a
fungus Dr Nash and Total Transformation
the sponsors of this next segment
explain
I lost 33 pounds and 30 inches and two
months of dieting with no exercise and I
was amazed I wasn't hungry Dr Nash it's
great to have you on the show we have to
start with Michelle because you
transformed her life 33 pounds 30 inches
off her waist she did it in two months
tell us more about Michelle she did it
in two months and she did it with no
exercise now please understand I'm not a
big proponent of somebody not exercising
it'll always boost results but these
results were just too incredible not to
talk about so 33 pounds is a big deal
but 30 inches like that is a huge amount
of weight to drop in the midsection
today we're talking about candida which
is the fungus that presents prevents
people from losing weight do I have that
right you have that right is the fungus
Among Us that makes us stop losing
weight so one of the things you
mentioned with Michelle is she didn't
have hunger and Cravings that's a big
thing that a Candida overgrowth does is
it drives these hunger problems and
these Cravings that are really hard to
control because it it's not coming from
you it's coming from fungus inside your
gut
what are the symptoms of candida and
what is actually causing it yeah so the
problem with the symptoms of candida is
that they sound like everything else
difficulty losing weight weight gain in
the belly lots of hunger lots of
Cravings especially for carbohydrate
feeling gassy feeling bloated so ideally
you know if you have those symptoms you
might want to consider that candida is
an issue but wouldn't it be great if we
had a test that you could do at home
where you could verify for sure if it's
something you're dealing with and then
we could go in the right direction to
correct it and you have that that
at-home test what do people do if they
want to see if they have candida first
thing in the morning before you put
anything in your mouth you want to
deposit some saliva into a clear glass
of water so that you can see watch it
for about 60 seconds if you see this
white material dropping down into the
water that is the actual yeast coming
out of your saliva telling you that the
candida has overgrown and most likely is
driving your stubborn weight problem and
driving the hunger and the Cravings that
are so hard to overcome when you're on a
diet
it works I did this test once before
have that glass of water for me I put it
next to my bed stand at night so I woke
up in the morning I was ready to go and
do it if someone does come back it looks
like it's positive what should we do
yeah so here is where we want to set up
a specific protocol not only to
accelerate fat loss not only to
accelerate fat loss in the belly but to
aggressively Target the overgrowth of
that toxin because not only does it
cause stubborn weight issues but it can
cause all kinds of gut issues as well
and Dr Nash you have Solutions you have
specials as well what do you have this
week right so obviously if you do that
test that's positive or even if you
don't you're struggling with extra body
fat that you're trying to get rid of
we're doing the evaluations that are
normally 97 and we're doing them for
only 9.97 it is an online evaluation so
you don't even have to leave your home
there's really no excuse not to find out
what's causing that weight problem and
getting it corrected